[Music]
what are your thoughts on vaccines for
kids
the best answer i can give you well geez
that got complicated real fast
we have a brand new segment that we're
going to try out called lightning round
so here's the deal
we get calls from all over the planet
and email social media requests all this
and kelly and jen they've been compiling
these questions and they turn into shows
and what we don't want to do is ask
answer the same question over and over
and over so they just they get the pile
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
kelly wants to know these things for her
personal life too sometimes and so she
puts them on there as well
and so we've got this new segment called
lightning round here's how it's going to
work kelly is going to read from a
compiled list of questions that y'all
sent in or that she secretly planted
there and i got one minute to answer
them because rumor has it i talk too
much we also have an entire studio full
of people and by entire studio people i
mean there's one dude out there he's
incredible you just thumbs down me man
if i miss it okay so
part of this is going to be me on the
spot
partis is going to be
having to say i don't know off top of my
head or i have an expert that i would
like to call i might even say their name
like if i got this question i would call
this expert
some of it might be me just winging it
from the hip and some of it might be
right in my wheelhouse i don't know
exactly right the answer but we're gonna
go for it
so welcome everybody to the introductory
section segment called
lightning round here we go we ready to
party let's do it and by the way can we
just say
sarah and the in the graphics team look
how cool this is man it's amazing all
right let's do this
all right first question how do you know
when to stop fighting for your marriage
oh okay i think you should stop fighting
for your marriage
when
both of you have give one or both of you
have given up okay so if what if you're
fighting in the person you're fighting
with or what fighting for on behalf of
is not interested in participating they
have stopped being a part of the
marriage
then i'm gonna lay
the weapons down we're done number two
if i'm fighting somebody i'm not
fighting you we're fighting for this
thing i'm not fighting you and i would
say the third thing how do i know
if i've decided that i'm out
if i've decided i'm out and we often
think we'll all know when i'm out when i
decide to quit fighting no that's not
true if you're in the marriage if you
want this thing to work if you want to
be a part of this thing then you're
going to keep going the moment you say i
can't do this anymore and i'm beginning
to step out that's when it's over is
that a good answer i don't know what do
you think works for me all right
all right let's go
do you agree with the quiet out method
for babies no i do not
i don't um
uh
no i don't um and i know i get a lot of
flack for that on the internets and i
don't care um
the best way to to for true behavior
change is through connection not through
disassociation not through fracturing a
relationship and so when a baby cries
it's a primal instinct it is a response
hardwired into a child that says i need
to be reconnected that is not a
thing when a child quits crying that
means they've exhausted their bodies
right um so not a their body's ability
to say i need help i need help and then
they get quiet and quiet isn't them
learning how to be still with themselves
quiet is their body going into the free
it's fight or flight or free it's their
bodies starting to shut down okay
um
so no i'm not a fan of cried out
all right next question how do you boost
sex drive
number one it
starts with good tunes right
um how do you boost sex drive uh well
i'd say number one sex drive isn't a
thing um sex drive isn't isn't real
um sex is as emily gatski suggests is a
series of um gas pedals and breaks
and so if you want to increase
sexual
encounters in your home you want to
increase intimacy in your home you're
going to look at the entire context so
for some people sex starts with the
amount of dishes in the sink and how
much we've talked this week and
sometimes sex is what you're wearing or
what you're not wearing or coming out of
the shower with a towel on your head
that's a signal that we're done for the
night or coming out of the shower right
so
it's all contextual so if you want to
boost that overall with in in your home
you're gonna sit down and have a
conversation about
how do we turn your owns on and how do
we turn your offs off all right next one
next question
what are your thoughts about online
dating
i think online dating is a great way to
transmit information with one another
it's a great way to find people in your
area that you wouldn't otherwise find
because people don't just go to roller
rinks anymore and they don't go just
play go i was gonna say play bowling
because that works people don't go
bowling anymore um or they do they go to
a group of friends so the way people
interact or they quote unquote meet each
other that's the way people come into
contact with each other so i'm fine that
i've got my one of my oldest friends in
the world uh got married that way i got
family members who got um connected that
way that's fine i think
with a mistake we make is that we try to
do all of the quote unquote getting to
know you electronically
and remember this
electronic communication allows us to
transmit info
it does not allow us to get to know one
another or to connect with one another
full stop with a period at the end of
that sentence no i've got great friends
that i no no no you have great people
that you communicate with that you give
info to
but they're not your friends all right
next question what are your thoughts on
vaccines for kids
the best answer i can give you well geez
that got complicated real fast
um i give my kids the the
what is it the mmr my kids have that and
i keep them up to date on that i did not
choose to get my kids vaccinated with
code vaccine for a number of reasons the
data told me that um and i'm vaccinated
my wife's vaccinated but when it came to
kids
the
downstream response was so
um the data didn't back it up i'll just
stop there so
and i by the way i partnered with my
doctor on that choice it wasn't
something i got off the youtubes
anyway
all right thanks for that so it was fun
having a show guys
i'll give you an easy one do you like
pop tarts
if there's a pop-tart and it's got
frosting on the top of it
sometimes i like to like take the
wrapper off real slow and just rub it on
my face
and just hold it there
yeah i do like pop tarts but only the
ones with this with the stuff on the top
of them uh if they're just pop tarts
with stuff inside of them yeah i need
both
well that was disturbing all right
why do people cheat
i
uh
man people cheat for a whole bunch of
reasons i think the most convicting
explanation of cheating that i've heard
is from esther perel which is this
most people who cheat
have not found something wrong with
their partner
they don't like who they have become in
the relationship
they have become boring they've become
isolated they've become alone they've
become
less sensual they've become frustrating
they've become angry they've become
whatever adjective you want to describe
but it's a description of yourself not
of your partner now there are people who
are abusive there are people who are
emotionally and physically not present
right which automatically leads to an
arc
of behavior right so somebody doesn't
show up and at home they're abusive
their whatever i'm gonna go find
connection with somebody else right and
i get that that's plausible
but often it's the not showing up it's
the this person is not safe and i become
somebody that i don't wanna become
all right next question this is the
worst by the way this is like torture
for me
to have a lot of fun for us though ah so
great my wife would kill for this
just this a button that shuts me up
after a minute
ugh
what's the difference between counseling
and therapy
the difference between counseling and
therapy so counseling is um
it's become like a colloquial term for
advice giving
and it's not but you have like addiction
counselors and you've got camp
counselors and you've got pastoral
counselors and you've got professional
counselors so when i use the word
counseling
i use it in the um professionalized
sense not as an advice giver but as a
therapist and so in its truest sense a
therapist and a counselor are the same
therapy and counseling are the same
when it's used interchangeably with
other things i was talking to somebody
the other day they're like yeah i was
counseling a couple and i was thinking
you're not a therapist you're not a
licensed counselor so you were just
sitting down and talking with somebody
and you're giving them advice that's
totally different so in that case
know this
therapy is not advice
therapy is walking alongside somebody as
you all co-discover what's the next
right step for somebody it's not just
lecturing somebody all right this one is
similar to that one how do you break up
with a counselor or therapist
a therapist or counselor is a
professional relationship they are not
your friends so there is no breakup the
same as you would call a different
plumber the same as you would
um
i don't know get a different yard person
you are going to choose to enter into a
new relationship now here's where that's
a little bit messy number one counseling
is intimate therapy is intimate you
discuss things with other somebody that
you don't just talk with everybody about
and so you feel attached to that
relationship
so understand it's going to be awkward
for you and treat it as a professional
relationship the second thing and this
is really important
is
some sort of grenade throwing like they
weren't good for you so i'm gonna tell
that that never is helpful it's not
cathartic it's not gonna make you feel
any better so you don't need to do that
the third thing is if they violate
ethical boundaries if they violate
confidentiality they lie to you about
price they don't talk to you about
confidentiality they ask hey can um you
do something for me by the way these
unethical things then you file that case
with the local um uh ethics board right
with the ethics board there you go
all right last one
what is the difference between counter
cancel culture and accountability
accountability is done number one in
relationship this is a great question
accountability's done in relationship
i've given you permission to speak into
my life
or
we've all live in the same society so we
have a responsibility to serve one
another with accountability but
accountability always serves to help
both the situation at large society um
this school building this group of
parents your kids and accountability
helps you it's me giving you wisdom and
insight and
holding you to a set standard that we've
all agreed upon
cancel culture is i'm gonna kill you
i'm gonna end your ability to earn a
living i am going to your ideas and your
words are so bad that i am going to end
your ability to use them
one of those is for building everybody
up
including somebody that has to have be
held accountable they have to be po
there has to be a punishment right um
cancel culture is the act of destruction
that was it i hated that
we'll be doing it again of course we
will
because i could see all high-fiving each
other back there you're like yes we got
him
so america if you like me stumbling
through my answers oh geez
that was hard
yeah those weren't easy questions if you
liked the lightning round let us know
go down in the comments below or send
kelly an email her cell number is i'm
just kidding i won't do that uh go to
john delany.com ask and put it in there
and if you have lightning round
questions like hey what's this this or
this or this let us know